the business secretary quasi quartens
says a criminal investigation into piano
ferries has begun following the
company's decision to fire 800 employees
without consultation he tweeted
following my letter to the insolvency
service last week formal criminal and
civil investigations into piano ferries
have now commenced transport secretary
grant shaps and i will continue to
follow this matter closely as the
investigations progress uh well let's
cross to the city now and our business
presenter ian king and ian certainly
damage for piano ferry's reputation but
also it seems damage limitation from the
government
i think that's very much the case
because if you remember last week both
quasi-kartang and grant chaps the
transport secretary were threatening to
haul piano in front of the courts and it
turns out that they haven't been able to
do that piano ferries i should stress
absolutely nothing to do with p and o
cruises what's happened this afternoon
as you say is that the insolvency
service which was contacted by quasi
kartang last week has now formally
commenced formal criminal and civil
investigations into the circumstances
surrounding the recent redundancies
announced by pierno ferries the
insolvency service has gone on to say
that these are ongoing investigations no
further commentary invest or information
can be provided at this time however sky
news understands there are three grounds
under which piano ferris is being
investigated by the insolvency service
the first of this is that the piano
ferris didn't consult workers or unions
the second is that it didn't consult the
secretary of state it didn't notify the
secretary of state about these
redundancies and the last point under
which they're being investigated is
concerns over the conduct of piano
ferris directors and i think actually
that is probably going to be the key one
because if you recall last week peter
hebelthwaite the chief executive of
prenatal ferries appeared before the
transport select committee and he was
asked why didn't you go before the uh
why didn't you consult the unions why
didn't you tell the secretary of state
and he basically said well there was no
circumstances under which any union
would have agreed to negotiate and so he
effectively admitted that the company
had broken the law and his point was
that piano ferris was making uh
compensation payments to the employees
some 786 of them at piano ferries over
and above the statutory minimums in
order to compensate them for the fact
that there had been no consultation and
i think that's really what stuck in the
crawl of ministers the fact that you've
had the chief executive of this company
brazenly stating in public that uh the
company broke the law because there was
no alternative and interestingly if you
talk to a lot of uh business people
behind the scenes well they were they
actually have a lot of sympathy for
peter hebelthwaite particularly because
the union involved in piano ferries here
is the rmt union which uh has a fairly
robust reputation it's fairly uh fair to
say they've uh quite happy to go out on
strike on many occasions and uh hit
london commuters for example on a number
of occasions including in the last month
or so so a lot of business people behind
the scenes say well this guy was
actually given no choice because there
was no way that he could have negotiated
with a union like that and got them to
agree to the terms that he was offering
so it's a pretty uh difficult situation
i suspect the insolvency service will
have a different view on things than
that the the kind of penalties that they
can reach for ultimately include
striking off the directors of uh of
piano ferries and barring them from
being a director of a of a public
company in the future one suspects that
might be what is coming down the line
because the government is plainly
looking for a scapegoat in this
particular instance particularly the
fact that they haven't been able to
reverse these redundancies and i should
stress by the way according to piano
ferries nearly all of the 786 people
involved here and now are actually
signing up for the redundancy terms on
offer but ultimately the government will
be looking for a head on a stake here
and one suspects it will ultimately be
that of peter hebelth weight